c'est l'heure de notre second débat
consacré à la guerre en Ukraine les
combats solidars la Grande-Bretagne qui
va livrer des chars lourds la Russie qui
pourraient en est aux conditionnelles à
mobiliser 500000 hommes supplémentaires
beaucoup de thèmes aborder avec nos
experts mais d'abord la situation dans
la ville de ni pro dans cet immeuble
d'habitation qui a été détruit selon
toute le vraisemblance par un d'ici rue
mathiasaraye il était presque 16h samedi
lorsqu'une frappe russe a ravagé cet
immeuble dans la ville de nitro à l'est
de l'Ukraine
ma fille et son mari était à la maison
ils ont été sortis des décombres tout va
bien pour eux ils ont eu plus de chance
que nos voisins
quelques heures seulement après
l'attaque on dénombre 40 morts dont
trois enfants un bilan qui pourrait
s'alourdir car deux jours après la
frappe meurtrière plus d'une trentaine
de personnes sont toujours portées
disparus
un jour c'était écoulé ma mère n'a pas
encore été retrouvée 5 étages sont
effondrées c'est triste
Kanya le président ukrainien volodi
mirzelinski a condamné hier cette
nouvelle attaque envers des habitations
civiles dans laquelle le Kremlin ni tout
implication je veux dire à tous ceux en
Russie et de Russie qui même maintenant
n'ont pas pu prononcer quelques mots de
condamnation de cette erreur bien qu'il
voit et comprennent tout parfaitement
votre silence lâche votre tentative
d'attendre que ça passe n'aboutira qu'au
fait qu'un jour ces mêmes terroristes
viendront vous chercher
ce week-end c'est également le sud du
pays qui a été la cible de frappe les
villes de crise et Kerson ont essuyé
d'import bombardements faisant au moins
un mort et une dizaine de blessés selon
les autorités locales je vous présente
tout de suite les invités du second
débat de ce sens public le général
Christophe Gomart bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue ancien chef du renseignement
militaire à lazareah bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi vous êtes rédactrice en chef
adjoint du journal
ukrainekitienne seul journal ukrainien à
avoir lancé une page en France Florent
Parmentier bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi secrétaire général du Cevipof
Sciences Po chercheur associé au Centre
de géopolitique de HEC et Mathieu
croissanto est resté à mes côtés
évidemment je commence avec ce
bombardement on vient de voir le sujet
de Mathias de ni pro général Goma est-ce
qu'on sait quel type de missile a été
utilisé quelles infos on a aujourd'hui
peut-être pas d'ailleurs si facile de
répondre à la question alors c'est pas
facile évidemment je crois qu'on pense à
missile
qu'a quelque chose d'une masse d'une
tonne ce qui doit correspondre à peu
près à plusieurs centaines de kilos de
d'explosifs à l'intérieur donc
effectivement on voit bien sur les
images cet immeuble effondré que la
frappe a dû être forte et en tous les
cas à détruit les dix étages ou les neuf
étages que comporter l'immeuble alors
après qu'est-ce que les Russes visées
est-ce que c'était l'immeuble lui-même
est-ce que c'était quelque chose à côté
et donc j'allais dire ça a été mal ciblé
mais ce qui est toujours possible est-ce
que c'est suffisamment est-ce que c'est
un missile suffisamment précis pour
frapper juste ça je l'ignore ce qui est
certain c'est qu'en tous les cas ça
participe de la de la terreur que les
Russes mettent en place avec la
destruction des des sites de production
énergétique avec différents sites civils
en tous les cas pour essayer de faire
baisser la tête de la population
ukrainienne qui en fait pondent une
résilience comme comme jamais
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait ça ne renforce
que la capacité de résistance
ukrainienne finalement ce type de
destruction au-delà malheureusement des
nombres morts qui ont casulé cette
frappe elle a la lazareah côté ukrainien
est-ce qu'on a justement des
informations sur celui-ci sa ça a
vétusté ou pas d'ailleurs en fait notre
parquet général a fait la déclaration en
disant que cette missile de classe x 22
c'est une missile qui est une missile
qui s'utilise contre les porte-avions
contre les grands bateaux et avec une
marge de précision assez large donc qui
a une grande en fait une précision pour
viser et que justement elles sont
largement déconseillées pour les
endroits où il y a les habitations où il
y a les
civils qui habitent donc c'est
relève au crime de guerre en fait alors
justement cette expression enfin c'est
de crime de guerre la présidente
suédoise de l'Union européenne là
utilisé on écoute
Ulf crysterson qui est le premier
ministre suédois vous savez c'est la
présidence tournante de l'Union
des enfants ont perdu la vie où ont été
blessés dans cette horrible attaque je
vais donc être très clair
les attaques intentionnelles contre des
civils sont des crimes de guerre les
personnes responsables de crimes de
guerre devront rendre des comptes
Florent Parmentier il y a une définition
très claire est-ce qu'on peut parler de
crimes de guerre un peu tôt pour
répondre mais
d'après ce que nous dit là la présence
de l'Union ou les les retours côté
ukrainien à partir du moment où une
force d'armée ne tape pas des militaires
mes tables des civils effectivement on
rentre dans quelque chose dans une
volonté de destruction d'infrastructures
critiques qui ont pour mission qui ont
des effets militaires des effets
militaires c'est et civil même plus
largement c'est la première chose la
volonté certainement d'éloigner un
certain nombre de civils des zones de
conflits pourquoi tout simplement parce
qu'ensuite c'est plus simple de
continuer à frapper et de et de compter
donc ce premier qui a une stratégie
derrière un très vrai si c'est délibéré
il faudra le confirmer mais soit c'est
effectivement un type approximatif qui
qui est tombé qui est tombé soit c'est
délibéré si c'est délibéré
l'une des intentions c'est de mettre à
base un certain nombre d'infrastructures
critique de manière à accentuer les
effets de déplacement interne au sein de
l'Ukraine ce qui a pour ensuite pour
conséquence ou simplement de rendre plus
difficile un certain nombre de manœuvres
et partant de là ça renchérit le coup de
la guerre à la fois pour l'Ukraine mais
aussi pour les partenaires de l'Ukraine
et comme souvent bon bah le Kremlin là
on a le porte-parole du Kremlin regardez
ce communiqué qui refuse toute
responsabilité les forces armées russes
mais bon bah pas les immeubles
présidentielles ni les infrastructures
civiles elles bombarde des cibles
militaires bref ça c'est le discours
habituel officiellement tu as oublié
intervenir moi je me demande ce que ça
te dit de l'armement russe parce qu'il y
a une semaine on a eu une forme d'intox
vous souvenez avec le Kremlin qui disait
avoir tué je crois 600 militaires Ukrain
chemin dans trois endroits différents et
hors des journalistes sur place on
montrait les images on a vu que c'était
des petits dégâts dans dans des gros
bâtiments comme si au fond les Russes
étaient incapables de faire ce que ce
qu'il disait et là on a pour le coup une
frappe avec un missile donc nous dites
la provenance
de la Marine en fait pour les
porte-avion et qui fait d'énormes dégâts
qu'est-ce que ça raconte de de
l'armement russe peut-être le général
Gomar là-dessus on a moi je me souviens
d'un débat il y a quelques semaines où
on disait mais on a parfois l'impression
que l'armée russe est obligé de racler
les fonds de tiroirs pardon de d'être un
peu trivial est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce
que c'est un fantasme qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait je ne pense pas qu'il racle les
fonds de tiroir je pense qu'ils ont des
larmements extrêmement modernes en
particulier en terme de missiles
anti-satellite par exemple en termes de
missile
IP de missiles hyper Sonic ou de
torpilles hyper vélos ce que beaucoup de
pays de l'OTAN n'ont pas en revanche
qu'ils aient des des missiles ou des des
plus vétus c'est des chars plus vétustes
oui c'est à dire que les stocks sont
utilisés et quand je dis que ils sont
pas à l'OS pour l'instant c'est qu'en
fait ils ont une véritable industrie de
leur maman qui fonctionne ils sont
passés en économie de guerre et donc
leur but c'est de construire de nouveaux
matériels en tous les cas de réparer
ceux qui ont été détruits qui sont
potentiellement réparables donc ils ont
cette capacité là maintenant ce qu'ils
utilisent le plus le plus souvent en
effet ce sont des des
vieilles pas des vieilles trapanels dans
tous les cas des choses un peu anciennes
qui sans doute ne sont pas aussi bien
guidées que Paulette par exemple un obus
de canon César ou que peut l'être des
des tirs aimars américains ou qui
peuvent l'être des tirs des missiles
antimissiles patriotes américains ou
Cobra français donc oui il y a une
certaine vétusté un salon de matériel
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'ils en
manquent alors notre question centrale
dans ce débat c'est est-ce que le
conflit s'enlise évidemment la capacité
à la fois de l'armée russe et de l'armée
ukrainienne à s'armé et à se réarmer au
fur et à mesure que le le conflit on va
aller centrale écouter tiens par exemple
ce que disait l'appel lancé par le
président
ukrainien boliviemenski c'était il y a
deux jours
sur mon jeu poney
est-il possible d'arrêter la terre russe
oui c'est possible peut-on le faire
autrement que sur le champ de bataille
en Ukraine malheureusement non cela peut
et doit être fait sur notre terre dans
notre ciel dans notre mère dire nasqua
de Rona de quoi a-t-on besoin pour cela
des armes que nos partenaires ont dans
leurs entrepôts et que nos guerriers
attendent toutes formes de persuasion ou
de temps qui s'écoule ne peut arrêter
les terroristes qui tuent méthodiquement
notre peuple avec des missiles
et je propose à Steve Jourdain de nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau de nouveaux
rebons soirs Steve puisque le on vient
de l'entendre le président ukrainien
demande des armes et l'Europe a passé un
cap en quelque sorte donc un cap et en
train d'être franchi vendredi le
Royaume-Uni a promis l'envoi de Charlot
vers l'Ukraine c'est le premier pays
européen à aller aussi loin on va voir
le communiqué publié par Downing Street
les autorités de défense et de sécurité
du pays pensent qu'une fenêtre
d'opportunité c'est ouverte alors que la
Russie est sur la défensif sur la
défensive à cause de problèmes de
ravitaillement et d'un moral en berne le
Premier ministre encourage les alliés à
déployer leur soutien à l'Ukraine le
plus vite possible fin de citation les
chars qui ont été promis sont des chars
challenger au total 14 seront livrés le
Royaume-Uni qui plus que jamais confirme
donc son engagement aux côtés des
Ukrainiens Londres et le deuxième
contributeur après Washington en matière
d'appui militaire Thomas alors il y a
d'autres contributeurs européens qui ont
aussi promis des chars c'est le cas de
la Pologne et de la Finlande écoutée le
président polonais c'était la semaine
dernière
nous avons décidé de soutenir davantage
l'Ukraine une compagnie de Charles
léopard sera transféré dans le cadre de
la construction d'une coalition les
chars léopard se sont des chars de
production allemande ils sont moins
chers et plus performants que les autres
le problème c'est qu'avant de pouvoir
les envoyer Varsovie a besoin du feu
vert de Berlin et pour l'instant Thomas
et bassin peu oui l'Allemagne qui ne
donne pas son son feu vert et qui
rechigne elle-même a envoyé des chars
lourds en Ukraine et ça crée des romans
même en Allemagne à tel point que la
ministre allemande de la défense a dû
démissionner ce matin pas forcément pour
cette raison mais pour l'accumulation
depuis quelques heures on va dire la
pression est en tout cas de plus en plus
forte sur le gouvernement qui redoute
une confrontation directe avec la Russie
s'il venait à débloquer du matériel
lourd en Ukraine c'était vendredi
dernier il explique qu'il faut prendre
le temps de la réflexion
nous refusons de traiter à la légère des
questions aussi sérieuses que celles
liées à la guerre et à la paix pour
notre pays et pour l'Europe
un chiffre tomates 300 300 comme le nom
de chars occidentaux demandés par Kiev
selon le chef d'état-major
ukrainien cela permettrait de soutenir
une offensive d'ampleur face à la Russie
et nous dans tout ça vous nous direz
Thomas et bien nous ne fournissons pas
nous Français de charlour à l'Ukraine
l'armée considère tout simplement que
nous sommes pas en capacité dans livrer
alors qu'on le rappelle on est encore
engagé militairement notamment au Sahel
merci beaucoup Steve Jourdain pour tout
ces détails j'ai un Goma est-ce que
tiens on va commencer sur les chars
britanniques là donc c'est des
challengers
challenger 2 donc une quinzaine ça
change la donne ça change pas ça change
pas grand chose ça donne l'exemple ça ça
pousse les autres à faire la même chose
mais ça ne change pas la donne c'est à
dire en char c'est ce qu'on appelle dans
le genre militaire un escadron donc
c'est environ 100 tomes qui prompt les
équipages écharpe plus le soutien ça
change pas la donne sur localement sur
un plan tactique peut-être mais voilà
pour changer la donne et c'est ce que
disait le visage est à major des armes
ukrainiennes comme d'ailleurs le
ministre le défense ukrainien monsieur
rezzykov eux ils poussent à avoir entre
250 et 350 chars effectivement là ça
change la donne les Ukrainiens
aujourd'hui dispose environ 1000 chars
déjà mischard de conception ex
soviétique aux Russes qui sont sans
doute moins performants peut-être un peu
moins blindés plus léger en terme de
masse environ 10 tonnes de moins que les
chars lourds comme les challengers les
charléopard 2 ou les chars américains
Emma Abrams ou que le char Leclerc
d'ailleurs mais est sans doute moins
sophistiqué en termes de capacité
d'armement mais Florent Parmentier moi
je vous entends enfin là on parle de
char qui viennent de pays différents
j'imagine qu'ils fonctionnent pas tous
de la même façon
pour l'armée grenienne des petits soucis
de formation d'adaptation à ce matériel
il y a plusieurs choses jusqu'à présent
on a pu observer que l'armée russe avait
eu de grandes difficultés à gérer une
hétérogénéité de force
entre ces ministres entre les ministre
Wagner mercenaires et puis il y a des
difficultés en fait entre les différents
corps d'armée quelque chose qui était
tout à fait notable à tel point que
c'est probablement la raison pour
laquelle la Russie a nommer le général
guirassimov à la tête de l'opération
parce qu'on peut voir un lien de cause à
effet entre le défaut de cohésion un
tiers des armées russes et puis et puis
cette nomination il me faudrait pas
effectivement que
la très grande complexité de gérer la
foi des chars léopard des chars des
chars différentes nature
soit soit un problème pour le chef
d'état-major ukrainien en même temps il
faut reconnaître que les forces armées
ukrainiennes ont fait preuve
d'inventivité souvent sur plusieurs dans
l'utilisation des
imams dans l'utilisation dans la
capacité qu'elle a eu à couler le navire
amiral mozova donc il y a eu de la part
des militaires Ukrainiens beaucoup
d'utilisation plutôt inventives qui
étaient pas forcément dans les textes
d'origine exactement et ça ça veut dire
que quand bien même effectivement avoir
davantage de diversité entre les
différents chars et pas un avantage
je pense que ce point est très
probablement intégré dans les calculs de
Monsieur zalougny quand il dit
effectivement j'ai besoin de 300 chars
lourds j'ai besoin de 6 à 700 véhicules
blindés pour déplacer mes troupes et
puis de mémoire 500 au buzier c'est à
peu près ce qu'il a demandé c'est un
moyen aussi pour le chef d'état-major
des armées Ukrainiens de prendre un peu
à témoin ses partenaires internationaux
et de dire si vous ne me donnez pas ça
je ne serai pas en mesure de faire la
contre-offensive que l'ensemble de des
partenaires en fait souhaite que je
fasse donc il met en quelque sorte un
niveau d'exigence pour dans l'état de
ses connaissances et bien être prêt
[Musique]
faut pas qu'on essaie gourmand mais
c'est juste que
nous a agressé et c'est une paiement ce
qui a une vesti surtout dans le secteur
militaire ils ont pas construit les
écoles ils ont pas construit les routes
elles ont pas construit les hôpitaux ils
ont produit produits les armes donc pour
se défendre pour reprendre nos terres on
a besoin de plus d'armes voilà c'est
c'est le contexte qui est le dicte c'est
pas nos caprices ou voilà j'entends ça
mais est-ce qu'on peut encore en donner
c'est vrai parce que
à quel point on peut est-ce qu'on a de
la marge quoi pour enfants
ce qui est pas gigantesque puisque
l'armée ukrainienne n'en veut plus sur
ces 220 je crois que le taux de
disponibilité doit tourner aux alentours
de 70%. c'est à dire qu'en fait le reste
les 30% non disponibles ou indisponible
sont en cours de maintien en condition
de révision de on change quelques tuiles
du matériel parce que c'est cher
évoluent en permanence donc il en reste
pas beaucoup en fait il y en a on en a
quelques-uns qui sont en Roumanie pour
effectivement dans le cadre de la
défense de de l'OTAN des pays de l'OTAN
on serait capable d'en rajouter de là
les données
je n'en suis pas sûr en donnant déjà de
la mixité on parle de charles-léger
enfin c'est un char qui est équipé de
caméra thermique c'est quand même un
canon de 105 mm c'est c'est un bon char
qui est qui a été construit je crois
1977 le premier qui a été largement
utilisé par la guerre du Golfe qui était
utilisé pas mal au Mali encore récemment
donc c'est un bon engin donc la France
donne ce qu'elle peut en réalité on a
donné 25% nos tartieries voilà après
après j'allais dire est-ce que la France
accepte de ce défaire d'un centre de ces
matériels pour sa propre défense ou ou
est-ce que elle parce que je crois que
ça a été proposé à l'armée ukrainienne
c'est que on a donné je crois de 200
millions d'euros c'est-à-dire qu'on va
en fait on s'adresse en directement aux
industriels
il commande les matériels qu'ils
souhaitent maintenant effectivement
c'est les industriels ont pas des
chaînes de montage en quantité
importante des canons les canons au
César par exemple de chez Nexter il faut
je crois deux ans pour en construire un
ou alors il faut doubler les chaînes de
production mais ce matin qu'ils étaient
en quasiment surchauffe quoi bien sûr en
fait on a des chaînes de production qui
sont très limitées finalement parce
qu'on n'est pas dans une économie de
guerre on est dans une économie normale
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on est à flux
tendu et on a besoin d'un chat on le
commande et il arrive donc c'est tout ça
met du temps les chars Leclerc on les
construit plus depuis 2008 me
semble-t-il il y a un parc existant de
chars qui sont qui servent en fait à
continuer à entretenir les chats
existants ou à maintenir les 220 chars
utilisés par l'armée française c'est
pour vous dire de pièces détachées
absolument absolument donc voilà voilà
ce qu'il y a ce que la France maintenant
est-ce que l'ensemble est vous l'avez
signé tout à l'heure est-ce que le fait
d'avoir cette hétérogénéité c'est très
compliqué une armée d'avoir
10 chars de type différents en réalité
parce que derrière comment on fait là
maintenant comment est-ce qu'on comment
est-ce qu'on amène on apporte les pièces
détachées comment est-ce que les
munitions sont pas exactement les mêmes
c'est-à-dire que le challenger
britannique par exemple utilise du 101
mm mais qui n'est pas compatible avec
les autres canons de l'OTAN c'est-à-dire
qu'il doit avoir ses propres obus donc
est-ce que les Britanniques en ont
suffisamment je n'en sais rien vous
voyez ce que je veux dire que c'est sur
le plan logistique c'est effectivement
très très complexe est-ce que la
lazareva il y a ce sentiment enfin et
même factuellement d'un front qui s'est
un peu figé aujourd'hui depuis plusieurs
jours plusieurs semaines on peut dire ça
effectivement nier le Russe n'arrive pas
à vraiment à reprendre ni solidargne et
bac mot tandis que ils sont dessus
depuis vraiment beaucoup de temps ils
emploient les moyens monstrueux donc
mercenaires de Wagner et des autres
forces mais malgré ça quand même elle
avance très lentement et aussi
malheureusement notre contrat français
non plus n'arrivent pas à avoir les
résultats rapides et vraiment reprendre
par exemple la flèche de kenburg à côté
des personnes il y a les combats depuis
plusieurs déjà jour et bon le contrôle
presque mais pas tout à fait donc oui on
peut le dire alors effectivement parliez
de solidaire la Russie revendique la
victoire dans cette ville de l'est de
l'Ukraine ce que réfute cette officier
parachutiste du crayon l’écoute
l'armée est debout nous tenons bon nous
gardons la défense les garçons tiennent
bon tout le monde sait pourquoi nous
sommes ici tout le monde sait ce que
nous faisons ici tout le monde tient bon
tous les gars sont super
chier voilà parole de de terrain en
quelque sorte Parmentier c'est toujours
difficile dans de faire le le tri entre
ce qui est de la communication et ce qui
est la situation militaire est-ce que
les Ukrainiens ont de fait perdu cette
bataille de soleda
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il y a deux
batailles qui se jouent il y a la
bataille sur le terrain et la bataille
de communication la bataille sur le
terrain aux dernières nouvelles montre
que les forces ukraines sont encore
présentes mais de manière extrêmement
limitée sur Cedar alors nous ce sera
encore une autre histoire ce sera prolon
encore plus compliqué donc effectivement
ce sont des batailles qui durent depuis
plusieurs mois et qui sont là vraiment
pour épuiser de part et d'autre les
forces armées
d'un site beaucoup d'hommes avec cette
idée de matériel d'user au maximum et
une guerre d'attrition donc on essaie de
de faire le maximum de dégâts en fait de
l'autre côté de manière à anticiper
peut-être que un léger décalage à un
endroit fragilise en fait d'autres
d'autres éléments donc c'est ça qui se
joue puis à cette deuxième partie vous
avez raison de le mentionner qui est la
question informationnelle à savoir il y
a un intérêt tout à fait évident de la
part de l'Ukraine des agents craintes de
dire nous n'achions pas solidars nous
n'avons pas reculé et tout recule comme
ça on verra un très mauvais génial
puisqu'on sait depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant que l'armure n'a pas eu de
succès véritable depuis au moins le mois
de juillet et qu'en contrepartie on a eu
à partir de septembre une
contre-offensive ukrainienne qui a été
extrêmement dynamique et qui a permis de
faire reculer pour le coup le front de
manière significative
et puis il y a cette guerre interne de
communication au sein des forces russes
où on a d'un côté la mise Wagner qui
explique avoir été seul à l'origine de
la reprise et puis une armée russe pour
laquelle on a décidé de mettre l'ancien
chef d'état-major au premier plan de
manière à quelque sorte réaffirmer la
position de l'armée russe son unité
cette volonté d'aller de concerts
il y a des rivalités très claires à
faire entre la ministre Wagner le chef
de cette mini je suis en train de
rechercher son nom il me semble
Prigogine efghani Prigogine merci
beaucoup et l'armée russe officielle oui
c'est vraiment un jour de ce mot
rivalité c'est le bon mot il y a un jeu
de positionnement règle en règle
générale quel que soit le conflit le
rôle des mercenaires et parfois de faire
le seul boulot qu'on ne souhaite pas
faire endosser par l'armée puis ça
permet aussi de ne pas compter le nombre
d'hommes disparus puisque c'est une
autre j'allais dire c'est presque une
comptabilité parallèle quand on veut
maquiller des chiffres on crée on crée
une milice pour ça ce que ce qui avait
été fait dans d'autres conflits les
grandes sociétés de mercenariat
internationales existaient bien avant
Wagner c'est d'autres d'autres acteurs
qui sont observés donc oui il y a
clairement une une très très forte
rivalité à ce niveau là qui
qui certainement montre un peu les défis
pour l'armée russe car
ce manque de cohésion explique en bonne
partie les succès ukrainiens et pour
expliquer d'autres succès Ukrainiens en
cas de contre-offensives on a beaucoup
comparé Solidar au Verdun
ukrainien enfin c'est une étiquette
qu'on connaît est-ce que ça veut dire
que c'est une guerre de position comme
un Verdun on va se battre en deux ans
sur 16 km de long
pour rien ou est-ce que c'est un vrai
verrou qui débloque une situation et qui
prend ensuite déboucher sur la guerre de
mouvement
l'impression que ça donne c'est que
c'est un verrou qui laissera une
ouverture sur un autre verrou donc on
est on est sur une
j'allais dire sur un sur une dose de
combat qui malgré tout finira par
épuiser l'un des deux l'un des deux
camps de manière assez objective il y a
des richesses économiques à cet endroit
là je dis qu'il y a une mine de sel
c'est ça
donc le nombre dit effectivement
et j'ai lu aussi les
analyses des experts mais les terres qui
disaient que justement l'objectif des
prégogène c'est prendre contrôle sur ces
mines du sel donc on lui prête cette
désir des contrôler ses gisements
qu'est-ce qu'on sait de l'ambition de ce
chef des ministres Wagner
tas de choses mais en fait c'est
quelqu'un une personnage assez
reumbulèse que quelqu'un qui repris de
justice quand elle était jeune quelqu'un
qui avait le surnom de cuisinier de
Poutine donc quelqu'un qui possède
beaucoup de médias qui financent
énormément de comptes Instagram compte
télégram donc qui est aussi qui a une
grande influence dans le monde de
communication justement et dans la
guerre d'information dans la guerre
hybride oui il y a aussi beaucoup de
fermes de trolls en Afrique qui
l'entretient nous on le sent tout le
temps parce qu'on a sans arrêt par
exemple agressé par les tribus de trop
le Vénus justement des pays qui
normalement ne s'intéressait jamais de
ce qui se passe en Ukraine et on
comprend que c'est par exemple Mali ou
donc Wagner est très présent où il faut
la guerre de communication aussi contre
la France donc il y a tous ces enjeux là
qui voilà qui contrôle ou qu'il essaye
de contrôler et qu'il essaie de tous les
soucis ficelles qu'ils tirent pour
essayer de tirer les bénéfices
une guerre d'informationnelle Christophe
Gomart il y a cette info qui est
justement qui est paru il y a je crois
il y a deux jours le renseignement
ukrainien qui affirme que la Russie
prépare une nouvelle mobilisation de
500.000 hommes alors quelle fiabilité on
peut donner à ça et puis quels seraient
les conseils d'une telle décision alors
je pense que tout le laisse à penser et
d'ailleurs la nomination d'un guerre à
simov au-delà effectivement de résoudre
les problèmes de divergence interne est
également le moyen de montrer que
aujourd'hui la Russie met tout en oeuvre
toute l'armée russe est mise en oeuvre
pour dans cette opération spéciale
est-ce que c'est encore une opération
spéciale militaire ou pas ou est-ce
qu'on est encore le terme officiel je
crois que c'est celui qui est utilisé
par les Russes en tout cas mais en tout
cas on voit bien que derrière il y a une
vraie volonté russe de tout mettre en
oeuvre et moi pour moi la nommée à ce
carracy bof et là en partie pour ça tout
est en oeuvre pour effectivement vaincre
aujourd'hui on parlait de effectivement
d'un front assez figé à solédar ça
avance ça recule ce qu'ils ont pris tous
au lédard peu importe c'est assez figé
finalement chaque aucun des pays n'a la
capacité aujourd'hui de mener des
contre-offensives et en fait d'avoir un
deuxième échelon suffisamment fort pour
pour aller percer effectivement et
poursuivre l'offensive parce que une
fois qu'on a percé c'est bien mais les
troupes qui ont percé en général sont
assez ratées il faut derrière d'autres
qui viennent les remplacer pour bien
comprendre ça veut dire que le front
lui-même mobilise trop d'hommes et donc
il y a pas la capacité de devoir une
offensive absolument d'accord donc d'où
les Ukrainiens attendent l'armement
occidentale en nombre et les Russes
quant à eux ce qui peut changer le
rapport de force c'est effectivement la
masse humaine et pour ça ils ont besoin
de mobiliser d'abord ils enverront
printemps les gens qui sont mobilisé en
septembre même si certains ont déjà été
envoyés en fait les deux parties en
présence cherchent à rompre ce front
comment est-ce qu'on se feront en ayant
un rapport de force favorable les ans en
appuyant sur un abonnement sophistiqué
européen ou occidental et les autres en
comptant sur la masse humaine alors on
va écouter un extrait de discours du
dernier discours de Vladimir Poutine
c'était il y a deux jours et il était
optimiste on l'écoute
la dynamique est positive tout se
déroule selon les plans du ministère de
la Défense et de l'état-major j'espère
que nos combattants vont nous ravir plus
d'une fois avec leur résultat militaire
du prénom russe à la télévision
publique Florent Parmentier ça veut dire
donc on parle on est à peu près vous
êtes à peu près tous d'accord pour dire
que le front est plutôt stabilisé pour
ne pas dire enliser si on se projette un
peu dans dans les mois d'hiver là on est
on est depuis trois semaines en hiver
mais c'est plutôt un moment qui fige ou
alors au contraire qui peut être
favorable à une à une nouvelle offensive
du côté du chef d'état-major ukrainien
Valéry Isa Louvigny il y a cette idée
que une
nouvelle offensive russe pourrait
advenir au mois de février et ce ne sera
pas forcément des remèdes endroits
continuera à avoir des scénarios qui
peut être retenu c'est une guerre
d'usure sur darkmouth sur soldat utilisé
et de part et d'autre en fait utilisé
pour ensuite lancer une offensive qui
pourrait avoir lieu depuis la
Biélorussie avec probablement une idée
pas nécessairement d'ailleurs pour
refaire un siège de Kiev qui n'ont
absolument aucune chance de prendre
enfin une ville de 3 millions
d'habitants et vendre juste une masse
d'homme considérable pour prendre hier
soir on mène pour le coup une guerre
d'attrition jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire
on bombarde tout ce qui se passe à Kiev
soit c'est l'autre l'autre hypothèse
imaginez que le but ne soit pas de
prendre Kiev mais plutôt de d'aller à la
frontière avec la Pologne de manière à
bloquer l'approvisionnement en arme de
l'Ukraine ça c'est un scénario qui
pourrait qui pourrait avoir une en tout
cas quelque chose qui est prévu et
anticipé par le chef d'état-major
ukrainien et donc c'est peut-être là en
fait d'où viendrait le déséquilibre
épuisé
usé sur un front bien précis avant de
tenter une autre manœuvre pédagogique
garde d'attrition en détail c'est quoi
c'est quand on bombarde on veut tout
détruire c'est ça en fait mener des
mener un con cherche dans lequel on
cherche et à tous détruire et à user le
maximum d'hommes alors vous parliez de
la Biélorussie regardez ce communiqué du
ministère biélorus de la Défense qui
annonce donc des exercices aériens
tactiques impliquant des unités de
l'armée de l'air de la biologie et de la
Russie qui ont démarré ce lundi et
auront lieu jusqu'au 1er février
principal objectif de cet exercice
renforcer la compatibilité
opérationnelle entre les deux armées à
la Lazare arrive à comment et pas
seulement aujourd'hui depuis plusieurs
semaines l'Ukraine réagit-elle face à
cette menace biélorusse puis ensuite on
parlera de l'hypothèse d'une entrée en
guerre de la Biélorussie comment que
fait l'Ukraine depuis plusieurs semaines
sur ce front là sur cette frontière là
plusieurs semaines on est mine la
frontière avec la Biélorussie justement
il déclaration de ma chef
d'administration militaire de la région
des rives il a dit que toute la longueur
de toute la frontière en fait on essaie
de faire tout pour que les chars les
blindés les donc tous l'équipement
lourds ne puisse pas passer donc
en plus il faut savoir aussi que cette
frontière catenorde justement proche de
la Pologne il y a beaucoup de forêts et
aussi beaucoup de marées en fait donc
c'est très très suicidaire de
s'expérimenter pour passer par ces
marées avec les techniques lourdes donc
il y a aussi la nature qui joue pour
nous normalement plutôt on peut
anticiper le
une tentative de refaire la siège de
clef ça c'est possible on pense que
c'est plus dans l'hypothèse que la
l'idée de venir d'un côté de la Pologne
en fait
vois pas cette armée biélorus rentrée en
guerre
aux côtés de l'armée russe en tous les
cas je crois que son président reste
plutôt prudent et évite évite de se
faire en balade on vous écoute tout
faire pour ne pas rentrer en guerre on
ne voit que Poutine la visiter il a
vraiment freiné comme il pouvait donc il
accepte les entraînements comment ils
prêtent son territoire pour que
l'équipement russe puisse passer mais il
va pas plus loin et on voit qu'il ne
veut pas du tout aller plus loin
pourquoi pas Parmentier pourquoi Lucas
Ginko prend pas ce risque parce que même
si c'est bon voilà on est dans un régime
ultra autoritaire évidemment mais il y a
quand même une opinion quoi il y a quand
même une grande Patrice qui est très
majoritairement contre en fait et on
sent bien qu'elle n'a pas envie d'être
entraîné ça c'est le premier effet le
deuxième effet c'est que ça a été très
bien dit par le général Goma un peu
avant il y a pas de valeur ajoutée forte
à
je veux dire prendre avec soi l'armée
biélorus en revanche il peut y avoir ici
ou là des profils spécifiques qui
manquent à l'armée russe et là on peut
se dire tiens bah là en terme de
ressources si nous manque tel profil
mécano sur tel type d'inja là on peut
voir peut-être des personnes mobilisées
au cas par cas sur sur ce type de
compétences là et je pense que c'est je
suis évidemment plutôt d'accord avec
cette idée que il serait coûteux pour le
Alexandre locachenko d'entrer dans en
conflit mais ça ne ferait pas vraiment
de véritable différence Mathieu du point
de vue de l'OTAN ça change quelque chose
en terme de réaction en termes de non le
temps depuis le début on voit bien elle
ne veut pas entrer en guerre alors
Monsieur Stoltenberg demande de
l'armement supplémentaire que l'OTAN les
pays d'autant donne à l'avoir
supplémentaire mais on voit bien que le
temps ne veut pas rentrer en guerre et
depuis le début en fait on voit bien
cette réticence des pays occidentaux
c'est d'empêcher enfin d'éviter
finalement que la que l'Ukraine attaque
la Russie en fait que l'Ukraine se
défend des repousse les Russes jusqu'au
frontières de 1991 oui que les l'Ukraine
attaquent la Russie non c'est toute la
difficulté en fait d'où la refus des
Américains au départ de donner des
highmars avec des missiles avec une
portée 300 km d'où au départ la
non-volanté donner des missi patriotes
et petit à petit on voit bien
effectivement on voulait pas donner
d'armes offensive ont un char c'est
quand même offensif à canon aussi ça
n'est pas que défensif ça c'est côté
ukrainien mais s'il y a une coalition de
la Russie et d'état qu'on appelait
satellite autrefois enfin la Biélorussie
mais ça change pas
les pays de l'OTAN tant qu'à payer le
temps n'est pas attaqué et de mon point
de vue Vladimir Poutine fait très
attention à ça il n'a aucune l'intention
d'attaquer un pilotant parce qu'il sait
très bien qu'il y aura une réaction
peut-être Florent Parentis votre avis
là-dessus et peut-être aussi sur le
finalement le degré d'influence de
des États-Unis et peut-être de des
conseillers américains dans la stratégie
ukrainienne vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
ce qui est d'abord sur le temps et
ensuite sur la l'influence américaine je
pense que sur le temps effectivement on
a eu une doctrine qui est finalement
assez fidèle à ce que ce qui avait
proposé Joe Biden Joe Biden a été l'un
des premiers à mentionner le fait qu'il
y avait une concentration anormale de
pente et avait même anticipé quasiment à
une heure près en fait le jour de
l'attaque et l'heure de l'attaque je
crois que c'était juste une heure de
décalage horaire par rapport à ce qui
était mais syndrome de Cassandre on a
plus de mal à croire les États-Unis
quand ils nous ont annoncé partout en
Irak avait des armes de destruction
massives et qui a du jour au lendemain
nous annonce effectivement de nouvelles
choses il y a eu une incompréhension de
ce point de vue là y compris des
Européens il faut se là dessus en voir
un petit peu le point mais qui
s'explique aussi tout simplement parce
que
quelques jours avant le début de la
guerre je pense cette grande conférence
qui a lieu la conférence pour la
sécurité à la Munich en février 2022 il
y a encore une incertitude assez je
pense du côté du côté ukrainien où il y
a eu en quelque sorte un espèce de
bascule où le 23 au soir 23 février au
soir donc la veille pouvait encore aller
au café et dans des enfin et au
restaurant mais le 24 au matin on a tout
de suite basculé en dans une dans une
nouvelle réalité peut-être plus
rapidement encore finalement que que
nous autres donc il y a cet élément là
nous restons un peu de ce point de vue
dans dans j'allais dire dans ce que ce
qu'avait annoncé Joe Biden à savoir
il y a des lignes rouges à ne pas
franchir on n'a pas vu d'armes chimiques
au loin de ce conflit
et plusieurs fois l'hypothèse avait été
évoqué on n'a pas vu d'utilisation aussi
heureux d'armes d'armes nucléaires
tactique ou quel que soit le nom qu'on
puisse lui donner de faible charge tout
ça on ne l'a pas vu je pense que ça fait
partie des différents points il y avait
il y a quelques semaines du reste cette
rencontre entre le chef du renseignement
américain et le chef du Renseignement
russe en Turquie
avec l'idée tout simplement de prévenir
un peu des différents points mais mais
une fois chef du harcèlement américain
et russe oui
ça peut sembler étonnant donc donc on
continue de discuter quelque soit du
reste pendant la guerre froide quel que
soit les dents il y a froid avait deux
oppositions en terme idéologique etc
mais il y avait aussi des passages et
des moments de discuter pour que éviter
précisément qu'on aille alors au-delà de
l'existant ça c'est effectivement
passionnant et puis ça ça rentre dans
notre débat sur la question de l'avenir
de ce conflit Christophe gobart est-ce
qu'il peut se terminer autrement que par
des négociations enfin derrière ça c'est
quoi la victoire quoi le problème est le
problème est bien là c'est que
aujourd'hui aucun des deux pays
enfin les deux pays estiment qu'ils
peuvent obtenir la victoire qu'il
souhaite d'un côté l'Ukraine pense
qu'elle est capable de repousser je vais
conforter 91 la Russie et les Russes
pensent que ils sont capables de au
moins tenir il y a 18% de territoire
ukrainien qu'il détiennent aujourd'hui
voir
donc en fait aucun des deux pays pour
l'instant ne veut la paix et une
victoire s'il y a pas de victoire
militaire sur le terrain la seule issue
possible c'est une négociation mais
comment est-ce qu'on rentre à
négociation avec deux gens avec deux
pays qui veulent pas se parler et je
comprends les Ukrainiens qui est pas du
tout envie de parler aux Russes
donc je ne sais pas et c'est pour ça que
pour moi ce conflit est amené à durer
malheureusement mais la réalité c'est
bien celle-là c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
à peu près deux forces en présentes à
peu près équivalentes grâce à leur maman
occidentale de l'autre côté grâce à la
masse humaine de l'autre donc en fait
c'est quelque chose qui va encore durer
je pense encore quelques mois
si ce n'est quelques années
malheureusement
c'est inimaginable pour les Ukrainiens
en général de
devoir un volonymer Zelinski négocié
avec Vladimir Poutine c'est de la
science-fiction aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on ne pense justement que tant que
Poutine et au pouvoir il n'y ait pas
possible imaginer une vraie paix on peut
se essayer de nous imposer c'est plutôt
les négociations qui peuvent donner la
possibilité aux Russes de se reposer un
peu et nous ré-attaquer réattaquer de
nouveau donc reprendre la fin de cire et
on ne croit pas une seconde aux paroles
de Poutine donc effectivement avec
Poutine on ne veut pas négocier et
Zelinski je pense qu'il a déclaré même
que il parler au futur dirigeants de la
Russie mais pas à Poutine il y avait une
de déclaration comme ça et si on prend
le pignon le pignon aussi je pense que à
peu près 22 25% ils disent que la paix
n'est pas possible on veut la paire on
ne veut vraiment la paix parce qu'on ne
souffre le plus mais les vraies P et pas
le fond donc c'est le décomposition de
l'impérius en fait tous les imperfs de
composteurs c'est la dernière qui reste
et une fois qu'il ne sera plus admiseur
de agresser ses voisins là la paix
viendra oui mais généralement
parlez-vous parliez d'économie de guerre
je veux bien vous vous entendre on va
terminer là-dessus en Parmentier c'est
c'est un effort parce que on se dit il y
a des sanctions économiques
internationales la Russie devrait être
affaiblie par ses sanctions et pourtant
il y a capacité quand même à se
recentrer sur une économie de guerre
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
oui il y a des effets sectoriels des
sanctions sur l'aviation civile et on
n'a pas besoin d'aviation chez lui dans
une économie de guerre si on regarde le
les chiffres du PIB c'est du moins 3
moins 4% Russie c'est à la fois une
année normale ce serait très important
mais par rapport à l'ensemble des
sanctions effectivement c'est
relativement limité la vraie question va
être moins la question de la confiance
de d'un partenaire avec l'autre
partenaire parce que dans une
négociation il faut mal et tout qu'on
soit de partenaires mais la question
très simple qui est qui aura le plus
d'armes à la fin de manière à pouvoir
garantir ses fins c'est c'est
malheureusement comme ça que les choses
risquent de se terminer et
j'allais dire le la dimension morale de
ce type de d'accord en fait et très
compliqué à mener à bien et par ailleurs
se posera la question ensuite de la
reconstruction Ukraine qui est le chemin
d'après et de savoir dans quel
circonstances bien on pourra mener ce
travail qui occupera les Européens pour
travers semblablement encore au moins
une ou deux décisions c'est un peu
brutal ce que je veux dire mais est-ce
que c'est la contrepartie de l'aide quoi
vous aide mais on sera là pour
reconstruire et nos économies finalement
en profiteront aussi à terme
certainement je pense qu'il y aura de ce
point de vue là des questions il faut
savoir que pour l'économie européenne
également le conflit n'est pas neutre
même si on ne peut pas
faire la différence entre nos types de
sacrifice qu'on peut faire et ce qu'on
voit de l'autre côté il y a je crois
qu'on disait en 2014 en Russie cette
expression qui disait en substance la
guerre entre le réfrigérateur et le
téléviseur et en gros on était très
contents de voir le téléviseur pour dire
voilà il y a tel ou telle avancée ça
c'était l'opinus la question du
réfrigérateur qui est importante une
nouvelle vie merci beaucoup pardon de
nous avoir interrompus merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat voilà c'est
la fin de de cette émission je vous
donne rendez-vous demain à la même heure
et votre prochain rendez-vous politique
sur notre antenne sur Public Sénat Boris
Vallot le prénom egook PS à l'Assemblée
qui sera la vitesse Dorian Mancini
demain c'est à 8h belle soirée